[BUZZING]
Everything you learn is
interesting about honey bees,
and I'm also very
interested in behavior.
And especially like
social complexity
of a lot of the animals
really fascinates me.
And honeybees have one
of the most complicated
social structures.
Every day is different.
Sometimes I'm in
here doing this,
sometimes I'm outside for
five hours with the bees
or doing molecular
stuff or anything.
Every day is
completely different.
DUAN COPELAND: Everybody
knows how important bees
are to our environment.
So I almost feel like
I'm able to contribute
to science helping us
understand honeybees
and how their microbes influence
their health and behavior.
I was interested in
microbes since my time
as a medical laboratory
tech in the Army.
Being able to contribute to
the growing body of knowledge
on honeybees has just been awe
inspiring and life changing.
[BUZZING]